We're still looking for a way of
dealing with non-additive matrices.
So in this section, let's try and
develop a heuristic.
In practice, researchers often assume
that every internal node of a phylogeny
corresponds to a speciation event,
which is defined as an event where
one species divides into two.
In this case, we need to place limits
on the internal nodes of the tree.
For example, if we're working with
unrooted trees, our requirement is that
every internal node
needs to have degree 3.
This means that regardless
of where the root is,
when we progress from the root to a leaf,
every time we encounter an internal node,
the tree splits into two pieces.
For example, if we place the root on
the limb of the squirrel monkey here,
then as we progress through the tree,
it splits into two pieces,
splits, splits, and so on.
If we root the tree, then, at that location,
we obtain the following
rooted binary tree.
Our goal, then, is to design
a heuristic that models
a "molecular clock" that
assigns each leaf an age.
The age of each leaf node is 0.
And then we need to assign
ages to the internal nodes.
The age of an internal node is
going to represent how long ago
the speciation event represented
at that internal node occurred.
So for this monkey phylogeny,
the ages are in millions of years.
Once we assign ages to the nodes
of a rooted binary tree,
we get the weights of the edges
of this tree (here shown in red)
simply by taking the difference
between the ages.
So for example,
the age of this node is 33.
The age of that node is 23.
We get the edge weight 10 for
free just by subtracting the two ages.
Furthermore, if we assign ages
to the nodes of the tree,
then it automatically implies that
the tree is what's called "ultrametric",
meaning that the length of every path
from the root to a leaf is the same.
So, here the age of the root
is 33 million years, and
the length of any path from the root
to a leaf node is 33.
The heuristic that
we're going to introduce for
constructing an ultrametric,
rooted binary tree
is called "UPGMA",
which stands for "Unweighted Pair
Group Method with Arithmetic Mean".
UPGMA is going to construct
an evolutionary tree
by clustering the species from
the distance matrix into larger and
larger clusters,
beginning with single element clusters.
At each step, it looks for
the two closest clusters,
according to the average
distance among all
pairs of elements taken
from the two clusters.
Now, at this stage of the algorithm, we're
dealing with single element clusters, so
if we're looking for the closest clusters,
that's just the smallest element
of the distance matrix,
which corresponds to k and l.
Now, I hope you're worried because
we've seen the perils of choosing
the minimum element of
a distance matrix as neighbors.
But UPGMA is a heuristic, and
it's not going to break like
adding additive phylogeny did.
So once we've found the two
closest clusters, C1 and
C2, we can merge them
into a single cluster, C.
Here we put k and l into a cluster
together because they're the closest.
We then conform a node for C and
connect that node to both C1 and C2.
We then set the age of this internal node
equal to half of this average
distance between C1 and C2.
So we saw that the distance
from k to l was 2,
so the age of this node is just 1.
We then recompute the average distance
between each pair of clusters and
we form an updated distance matrix.
Now, we then just begin this process over,
choosing a minimum element of our matrix,
merging the two associated clusters,
forming a new node for
the merged clusters (which here is (i,j))
and then assigning the age of this node
as half of the distance value from
the matrix, which was 3 here,
which gives us an age of 1.5.
After one more update
of the distance matrix,
our only choice is to merge
the remaining two clusters,
assigning an age of 2, and
this yields the final UPGMA tree.
Now, here is the outline of UPGMA
provided on a single slide.
Please feel free to just pause the video
here if you need a little more
time to understand the algorithm.
You should now be ready
to implement UPGMA and
apply it to the coronavirus data.
Of course, Son will complain because we
never have really stated a computational
problem that UPGMA is trying to
provide an approximate solution for,
but that's okay.
The goal of UPGMA is not to
fit a distance matrix, but
to provide a reliable method that always
can construct an ultrametric tree,
regardless of what the input data is.
So, we know that the tree produced by
UPGMA can't possibly fit this matrix,
because the matrix is non-additive.
You can see, for example, that
the distance from i to l is 3 in
the distance matrix, but
4 according to the UPGMA tree.
So in summary,
we've encountered two methods for
constructing an evolutionary
tree from a distance matrix.
Additive Phylogeny works if you give
it an additive matrix as input.
But then, on the other hand, it fails
completely on non-additive matrices.
Then, UPGMA, in contrast, will produce
a tree for any input that you like,
but the tree produced doesn't necessarily
fit an additive matrix in a natural way.
So, can we possibly hope for
an algorithm, one single algorithm,
that's going to combine the better
features of both of these algorithms,
in that it always produces the tree
that fits an additive matrix, but
it also offers a good heuristic for
non-additive matrices?